well uh good morning it's a pleasure to
be here um it's exciting to see so many
of you and hear some of these
presentations my name is Eric Breman I
was born in Venezuela a country that by
any measure should be one of the
wealthiest countries in the world not
just by aggregate GDP but by individual
Prosperity unfortunately when I was 14
had to leave my country of birth
initially in pursuit of better
educational opportunities but I never
went back due to the lack of
opportunities in general I started on a
quest as a young student from high
school onwards to University to think
about why is it that a country with so
much potential such as Venezuela ended
up with so much misery and poverty and
what I could do to help rid the world of
poverty
itself I realized that I was looking at
the wrong question that it isn't about
how you end poverty rather how you
catalyze
Prosperity thus over 20 years ago I
started on a quest for how to drive
maximum prosperity to the most amount of
people anywhere in the world I started a
company called New Way Capital which
ultimately led me to where I am today to
start prospera so Prosper is ultimately
a governance platform for parallel
societies because what we realized is
that a lot of the underlying issues that
hold back development that drive
Prosperity but also keep us from having
flying cars and living to 200 and the
most cool innovations that we hear about
is generally a lack of regulatory and
legal environment that is supportive of
as opposed to creating friction for um
the best best amongst us in society the
the entrepreneurs the inventors the
innovators so prospera set out to build
the city with the optimal legal and
Regulatory environment to maximize human
Prosperity but we quickly realized that
to say let's build a city is relatively
easy but to actually go through the
process well it's been multiple decades
and there many steps and the core
infrastructure necessary to even start
on a project like this is invisible it's
about politics it's about agreements
it's about regulatory Frameworks so I
want to mention to you a few of the
projects that we have I will be going
deeper in this presentation into our
first city on the island of rawan called
St John's Bay but I did want to
highlight a journey that we've been
through to share it with you and also to
invite you towards the end of the
presentation to join this very important
Journey
this scale at the horizontal is by no
means at scale the steps include not
just going from an idea to signing Lois
getting memorandums of understanding of
which we have several but then there's
this legislative step that must be
engaged upon if you're going to do this
in the context of partnership with a
sovereign nation which itself can take
you know 3 to 5 years if not 10 um our
first project on rawan has has gone
through most of these steps and we're
currently receiving our first movers and
on a quest to reach critical mass
defined by the operational apparatus
being cash flow
positive um all of this is built upon an
infrastructure of legal regulatory tax
dispute resolution security and
infrastructure Services which add up to
these four pillars these four
pillars within prosa provide provided as
a service enables us to play in the
governance as a service space we needed
it for our first city but we're able to
offer it for multiple cities running on
the same open-source governance platform
to make the process much more fluid
consistent and optimized for Innovation
and
prosperity the four pillars revolve
around the regulatory environment which
is an open source approach with full
reciprocity over all oecd countries and
a growing list of peer countries the
ability to propose new regulatory
Frameworks if you're in an industry that
does not already have a sufficiently
supportive framework anywhere in the
world or the ability to operate without
a prescriptive regulatory framework and
simply under common law as long as you
recognize you have no corporate Val
protection there are some taxes but
they're very low very simple and very
straightforward to comply with any
disputes get resolved through
arbitration exclusively and we have an
in-house arbitration Center to service
you with a relatively low cost and high
speed and all so-called public services
are offered privately and for
profit the quest to build our first city
has led us into a number of achievements
that we're extremely proud about
including having raised over $100
million so far to build the first city
over 1,400 residents physical and
digital we have over a th000 Acres
incorporated into the special
jurisdiction with over 160 Companies
Incorporated and over 4,000 jobs that
have been created within the local
economy so let me tell a little bit
about where our first city is at in
ratan because it's amongst many places
not only beautiful un underrated but I
think a very strategic location for a
project such as this to start with it's
on the western side of the Caribbean so
away from the hurricane belts which is
nice and very attractive uh we have
direct daily flights from Miami and
Houston in the US so it's very
accessible almost anywhere in the world
you can get to one of those two hubs
within one flight away it's a mostly
English-speaking population former
British colony uh less than 100,000
people live there yet the size of the
island is one square mile larger than
the island of Hong Kong where almost 1.5
million people live occupying less than
30% of the surface area on the island of
ratan we've started building this what
we hope will be beautiful city uh as a
place to build with real people in the
real world and in a real jurisdiction
many of us many out there that want to
do parallel Societies or New City
projects need a place to actually start
building in reality we began this quest
after a decade plus of legal regulatory
political
diplomatic efforts breaking ground in
the middle of coid with our first
building which we call the beta building
it's a mix use facility which has been
now occupied entirely by
offices currently working on our second
major project which is a mix use Tower
as well 14 stories residential and uh
commercial having in parallel negotiated
and finally closed the acquisition of a
pre-existing underbuilt
Resort of about 400 Acres which gives us
access immediately to not just a
beautiful golf course but wonderful
Beach Club amenities a hotel in which
we're hosting conferences we're already
booked the entirety of q1 of next
year uh we have a school within the
jurisdiction my kids I live there
fulltime my kids go to the school within
the city uh in partnership with GST
montor we even have our own Bitcoin
center with a Bitcoin ATM the only one
and first one on the island of
ratan um and I could go on one of the
other amenities we really enjoy revolves
around Golf and this is our own version
of top golf hitting right onto the
Caribbean
Ocean um but how do we scale how do we
go from having done this incredible
amount of work over the last decade or
so to create the foundations so that now
we can build up the first of what we
hope will be many cities well our
approach revolves around opening up and
creating Special Districts and inviting
alternative and additional Network and
parallel societies to come and build
with us Nomad earlier mentioned that
they're building one of their notes
within prospera and we're open to many
many more so that in reality what we
think of as a city is a community of
communities coming together in pursuit
of innovation in pursuit of your own
Visions but in an environment that
creates generalized
Prosperity we'll be launching a pilot
project called be Vu helping online
communities become onland communities
encourage you to take a note of this QR
code or when you have a chance Google
Unreal Engine sahah Hadid prosper and
Roatan and you get a deeper dive of what
this project is all about but in short
the ability of turning online
communities through an online
configurator into ultimately a physical
location where you can co- live co-work
and pursue your vision in
reality uh we're proud to work with many
of you already and uh look forward to
2024 being the year where we break
ground on several special district
projects um we are also launched the
city builders Network earlier this year
and this is if you can't move or if you
don't have a network Society per se then
you can join ours in the context of
helping build the city through decent
centralized efforts most major projects
can be uh decentralized if you bring
down to the tasks and let the community
participate so very excited looking
forward to hosting you in ratan when you
come visit there's more information this
QR code thank you very
much